well speaking of trade it was meant to
be a vehicle for bringing the u.s and eu
closer together
to a rocky period of tariffs and trade
spats
instead the trade and technology council
which meets for the first time in
pittsburgh in the u.s today has itself
gotten off to a rocky start now its
biggest success may be if a meeting
takes place at all our brussels
correspondent terry schultz has this
report
the trade and technology council or ttc
created at june's eu us summit is seen
as a tangible example of improving
transatlantic ties with the president eu
leaders have fondly called
the ttc's 10 working groups are tasked
with finding joint approaches on topics
ranging from artificial intelligence to
climate protection to securing supply
chains we need to team up and join up to
tackle the big challenges we have ahead
of us i think we have an opportunity to
do some really very good things but dear
joe's deal to sell nuclear submarines to
australia replacing a french contract
put a [ __ ] in his previously chummy
relationship with french president
emmanuel macron the spat threatened to
scuttle the ttc's launch but the eu
decided to go ahead over paris protests
this is bigger than that
in the sense that it has to do with our
entire economic relationship early ttc
priorities are addressing the global
shortage in semiconductors controlling
the export of sensitive technologies and
keeping foreign powers particularly
china from buying up key strategic
assets if the united states and europe
actually use the trade and technology
council
to really
look at this nexus between national
security and economic power
then it will be doing something
important but it will take time and in
the meantime the most important signal
from the ttc's inaugural session may
simply be a joint commitment to find
common ground to build on
now french fury over this dumped
submarine deal is definitely not all in
the past as recently as yesterday the
joint final statement and even the draft
agenda was still under debate among eu
governments held up in large part it's
reported by the french but again the
fact the meeting is taking place at all
is an acknowledgment of the centrality
of the transatlantic relationship for
both the united states and for the
european union and there are many issues
they need to work on that will be
win-win for both sides and lose lose if
they don't take care of them so while
there's a lot of work to do as everyone
acknowledges there's a lot of work
that's already been done in just setting
up this trade and technology council 10
working groups already arranged so i
think that while everyone may not be on
the same page already today on day one
the very fact that they're all going to
be at the same table is definitely proof
that both sides want to move forward and
get past these disputes
terry shorts in brussels thank you very
much